it's a fling keV calm exclusive the
wishes people say to you thank you see
you in public what's like something that
is acceptable that won't annoy you there
sir
besides yellow sub MGK can suck your
dick on the stripper was poppin I don't
know would you like that
I mean you one dislike it casual favors
Wakko's bipolar man like you I saw you
with John Cena I thought you're really
cool hey get a picture
we'll have eco I get that halogen like
looking at El Paso's Rose crazy cuz like
you know like the next day like the
messy feeling like really digs wrestling
oh yeah what right I got a Daniel Bryan
channel right now and so um I'll do
Tommy out I just I just want to be a
part of the people if you come up to me
and I know you're just coming to say
like what's up and not requiring things
from me I see them all the way there
with you man I've had hour-long
conversation with people because I look
for the person who's not gonna come up
be like you know like the douchebag with
this girl like oh hey I know you man hey
hey hey can we get a picture all day hey
is that what cross the street like hey
come here I'll be like dude movie I'll
be in the club I swear to god I'll be in
the club I don't want to talk to with a
grown man in the club of course not like
you didn't come here to talk to me and I
mean you may have I'm saying like you
should be here to like soak up the
experience of what's going on arrows and
you know the MGK music and us being
there you being like oh why you're
touring with a girl like all this
muhfucka NGK it's crazy I love this
environment but it's like like they're
like oh come he's like it's just like
why why like when I was a fan like we
remember talking about bleep like but
like when I about anybody to pot when I
was a fan like all I required them to do
was make good music
I said Donald cuz we didn't have twitter
back then we have some letters I
remember sending fan letters to like so
what you're 7f antlers - I send fan
letters to Obie Trice
work
uh to Eminem Obie Trice his first album
so slept oh my god we all die one day
grazie Amina's versal nears and that's
all at the whole thing right now uh
Hello Kitty slippers are humping it leg
yeah that's my [ __ ] my sorry uh blink
but like Oh be like I was believing like
I was really into like the darker me
like Oh be and all those people like
that but you know Thomas and Austen fan
later and I never expected respond just
one of them know how much I've dug that
[ __ ]
but now I was like if you don't even
follow somebody on Twitter it's like yo
[ __ ] you don't follow me I'm a [ __ ] y'all
I'm not a fan of you this is [ __ ]
you're one of my tweets that I spend all
day just sad the world is disgusting i
watch documentaries I'm like music back
of the days as it was so free they just
love to like they just the fans just the
fans back in the day even the fans in
the 90 so that was a 90 spent so like my
fan of somebody else is so much
different than Rosie I don't require
them to shake my head they don't have to
do anything to me I'm saying all they
gotta do is make a music but now it's
like you gotta you gotta like you know
I'm saying like go do get on over you
know stream and tweeting all this
[ __ ] me thank you coming through
Jesus all oh yeah well thank you little
more Twitter go get down lace-ups found
any point three hip out Liz